[Music]
America observers are fond of saying it
is the only country based upon an idea
that idea that all men and women are
created equal and have inalienable
rights to life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness is directly informed by the
Enlightenment the philosophical and
scientific movement that dominated
politics culture and ideas in the 18th
century but are we still an
Enlightenment nation the Enlightenment
principle that we can apply reason and
sympathy to enhance human flourishing
may seem obvious right Steven Pinker in
his new book enlightenment now the case
for reason science humanism in progress
he continues I wrote this book because
I've come to realize that it is not
obvious Pinker is a linguist who teaches
at Harvard and is the author of among
other titles the better angels of our
nature
the blank slate and how the mind works
has been named among the top 100 most
influential public intellectuals by time
and foreign policy and he's been highly
critical both of conservatives who deny
evolution and progressives who say there
are no meaningful biological differences
between men and women not surprisingly
enlightenment now has been attacked by
right-wingers who find it insufficiently
respectful of tradition and left wingers
who say it's an apology for capitalism
reason spoke with Pinkert about the need
to document not just material but moral
progress over the past several centuries
the ongoing need to defend free speech
and open inquiry and whether he's
optimistic that our future will be
better than our current day
let's start by defining the
enlightenment what are its basic pillars
and what is its what are some of its
impacts on the world and I guess those
are two very large questions yes
what what what comprises the
enlightenment my potted view of the
enlightenment identifies three or four
themes reason science humanism and
progress reason being that the ideal
that we analyze our predicament using
reason as opposed to dogma Authority
charisma intuition mysticism science
being the the ideal that we seek to
understand the world by formulating
hypotheses and testing them against
reality humanism that we hold out the
well-being of men women and children and
other sentient creatures as the the
highest good as opposed to the glory of
the tribe or the the race or the nation
as opposed to religious doctrine and
progress that if we apply sympathy and
reason to make people better off we can
gradually succeed why did the
Enlightenment happen when it did and
obviously you know it's it's not as cut
and dried as saying you know you know
when Kant wrote this that's the begins
the Enlightenment and then when you know
Thomas Carlyle said something that's the
end of it but you know why did it happen
when it happened because it only
happened once we don't really know and
we can't test hypotheses but some
plausible explanations are that it grew
out of the Scientific Revolution of say
the 17th century which showed that our
intuitions and traditional view of
reality could be profoundly mistaken and
that by applying reason we can overturn
our understanding of the world by the
age of exploration the fact that there
were entire continents that previously
were were unknown and that required
rethinking an entire worldview may be
more approximate technological
Kickstarter was the
the growth of printing technology
printing technology was the only
technology that showed a huge increase
in productivity prior to the Industrial
Revolution everything else had to wait
for the 19th yeah and you talk about how
I mean basically between the year a
thousand and about 1800 in many places
people had very little increase if any
and material well-being
yeah economic growth was was a sporadic
at best and and most technologies showed
very little increases in efficiency but
printing technology did take off in the
18th century and pamphlets were cheap
and available and broad sheets and books
and they got translated they were they
circulated across all of the European
countries as well as the colonies so the
exchange of ideas was lubricated by that
technological advance and another
possible contributor was historic memory
of the Wars of Religion and that showed
that dogmas about faith and Scripture
and interpretation and messiahs and so
on could lead to tremendous carnage and
they thought well let's not do that
again so these are all the ingredients
which one was causal we don't know a
large section of the book is it's kind
of documenting the you know incredible
progress that we've made by any I think
even the most anti progress person let's
say ok well yeah people are living
longer people you know fewer women are
dying in childbirth fewer kids are dying
in in the first five years old life what
it for you are some of the key markers
that show the impact of Enlightenment
principles or enlightenment thinking to
our world the certainly the conquest of
hunger the fact that now we've got this
problem called obesity the obesity
epidemic has historically as problems go
that's a pretty good one to have
compared to the alternative of mass
starvation and you mentioned in the book
if I'm not miss remembering and some of
the poorest parts of the world man
people are getting something like 2400
calories a day which in the u.s. that's
400 calories above what you know the
USDA recommends they middle-aged man
eats on a daily base so that's I mean
that's it that's a good thing yeah
there's still there's still as hunger
there okay there are famines in in
war-torn remote regions but by large the
famine is one of the horsemen of the
apocalypse has been has been teamed just
sheer longevity the fact that in the
world is a whole life expectancy now is
71 for most of human history it was 30
literacy the fact that 90% of people
under the age of 25 can read and write
in Europe a couple of hundred years ago
it was 15% and less obviously war has
been in decline over the past 70 years
or so the chance of getting killed in in
now war has plummeted crime has declined
even in a pretty crime country like the
United States well it's worth looking at
the long scale right because it's crime
actually started a a kind of violent
crime on a day to day basis started
declining in the late Middle Ages yeah
so that you can't we can't credit the
Enlightenment for that because it was a
kind of the transition to modernity
right but it was another yeah kept me
again I got another boost in the 19th
century with the formation of
professional police forces and with a
more systematic application of criminal
justice and then in the in the 1990s in
the 21st century with data-driven
policing like the New York's CompStat
program which put the police where they
where the crime was starting to grow
before it could explode in blood feuds
in cycles in Vendetta the whole idea of
having a prison sentence or or a
sanction against a criminal fit the
crime what was going on there and how
was that different then yeah you know
what had come before well prior to the
Enlightenment there were gruesome
criminal punishments for what we
consider rather trivial misdemeanors
like drawing and quartering you know
cutting a person open and ripping out
his entrails while he was still alive
and conscious I'm sure he was guilty of
something
poaching criticizing the Royal Garden
then in the 18th century largely through
the arguments of Cesare Beccaria who
coined the term the greatest good for
the greatest number later picked up by
Jeremy Bentham as the model for
utilitarianism he argued for
proportionality not so much to satisfy
some cosmic scale of justice that the
punishment must fit the crime just
because that's what justice is inscribed
in the heavens but just to set up the
right in the incentive structure he
pointed out if you're gonna apply the
Severus penalty to rather minor crimes
and criminals could just say well why
stop at that if I'm going to take a
chance I may as well go all the way kill
the witnesses kill the burgesses
families if I'm gonna get the same
punishment is just
burglarizing their house in the first
place so the the is a real rational
incentive based argument for what seemed
like kind of cosmic principle that the
punishment should fit the crime and it
was an example of just a rational
analysis of societal institutions that
went beyond gut feelings of
appropriateness went beyond just sheer
cultural inertia and said well what is
the rationale why do we you know what
why why should we punish more severe
crimes more severely I'm quoting you
here you say the world has made
spectacular progress in every single
measure of human well-being
here is the second shocker almost no one
knows about it
why don't we acknowledge it more some of
it is that we have no exposure to it but
that if you're if our view of the world
comes from journalism since journalism
is oriented to discrete events things
that happen not things that don't happen
there are as long as rates of violence
and hunger and disease don't go to zero
they'll always be enough incidents to
fill the news if since our intuitions
about risk and probability are driven by
examples the availability heuristic then
we can get a sense of how dangerous the
world is that's driven by whatever
events occur and we're never exposed to
the 100
thousands and millions of locales where
nothing bad happens that you can assess
with data because it goes into the
denominator you count the number of say
violent acts as a proportion of the
number of opportunities when you see the
data you realize my god our risk really
has gone down but if you're just being
exposed to particular criminal acts it
could seem the same as ever I think
there's also a moralistic bias at work
that pessimists are considered morally
serious and optimists are considered
when a frivolous as Morgan Housel put a
pessimist sound like they're trying to
help you optimist sound look at trying
to sell you something we attach gravitas
to the often to the the doomsayer you
start the book by invoking donald
trump's nog ural address and you know
where he talked about american carnage I
mean actually using those words and it
was one of those moments where it's like
you know I think a lot of people even
probably even some supporters of him
were kind of like what world like he
seemed to be describing New York City
Circuit 1975 as opposed to the United
States in 2016 is there a point where
having more sources of information
available actually well kind of
countermand the negativism of the news
depends on what the information isn't
how its presented
certainly if we had more attention to -
to data on trends as opposed to discrete
events that is if a news story on a
terrorist attack or a school shooting or
a drug overdose said oh and by the way
this has been a trend for the last 40
years or even last 20 years and if the
op-ed columnist did not interpret
yesterday's news as itself a trend if we
remembered that by definition one data
point is not a trend we need better off
also a little bit of history not not
going back centuries but even going back
say to the 1970s well that's what I
don't understand is the people who you
know can you know lived in the 1970s
should be calling [ __ ] on that kind
of stuff but you think do you does your
memory change as you age
that that especially the negative
coloring of events in the past tends to
fade so you remember everything that's
bad about what's happening now some of
the awful things in the past they lose
their their negative connotations how do
you prevent yourself from becoming paint
glossy and yeah ingesting because
there's no question compared to
certainly five hundred years ago we're
much better off so you know stop
complaining and you know of course but
Pangloss hasn't Matt really points out
was a pessimist yes the optimist thinks
that we can the world can be much better
than what it is today it does have
syphilis
so his world could be a lot better and
Voltaire was really satirizing widens
his argument for theodicy I mean we God
had no choice but to allow earthquakes
and tsunamis and plagues because a
better world was just ontologically
impossible and that that's what Voltaire
was satirizing well just to really to
stick with the data and to note that
some things really do get worse right
now for example the opioid epidemic is
clearly an example of something getting
worse and there have been it is
certainly not the case that progress has
been monotonic they've been fantastic
setbacks the the Spanish flu epidemic in
1918 1919 World War two the 1960s crime
boom AIDS in Africa lowered life
expectancy
so you've got to be aware of cases where
not only progress has gone backwards and
that could happen again
but also of low probability but high
impact events such as nuclear war such
as the possibility of catastrophic
climate change let's look at some of the
groups that are anti-enlightenment
in your argument and the first one I
want to talk about is the romantic green
movement who what what do you mean by
that phrase and who are these people
yes well my particular file for that
would be Pope Francis and I know that
arguing with a man who's infallible this
must be the ultimate exercise in
futility but it's also said you know
that's why you have tenure
exactly and
this is the the idea that human humanity
made a terrible mistake when it began
the Industrial Revolution that we've
been raping and despoiling the
environment which has been getting
steadily worse and worse and worse and
we will pay the price in a dreadful day
of reckoning will be poisoned by our
pollutants they'll be epidemics of
cancer they'll be cold and so even if we
did have 200 years progress from 1800 on
you know where the clock is about the
alarm is about to go off and
everything's gonna turn bad that's right
or in fact that the the progress that
even that we've experienced so far is
illusory since we're breathing in
carcinogens as we speak and since
species are dropping like flies and so
actually our situation is getting worse
and worse and worse
this movement tends to be opposed to the
technology driven increase in living
standards over the last couple of
hundred years tends to see humanity as a
scourge on the planet
and I in the book I acknowledged that
concern with the environment certainly
is a good thing and we have the green
movement to thank for reminding us that
that that can be arms to pollution and
however there is an alternative approach
to protecting the environment sometimes
called eco modernism or eco pragmatism
that first of all acknowledges that the
that pollution has been a price though
that we have paid so far for enormous
benefits to humanity more than doubling
lifespans emancipating slaves
emancipating women from domestic
drudgery and Men estate and thence
baiting children from farm labor and
getting them into schools that some
degree of pollution is worth paying just
as some amount of dirt in your house is
worth it because the effort to keep it
perfectly clean I would mean sacrificing
everything else good in life yeah and
this is part of the humanism right the
idea that I mean humans can it's it's
not that the world
this merely for us to you know blow it
up if we want to but rather that you
know a lot of green romantics don't seem
to put any value on human flourishing
such as for example an example would be
the implacable opposition to general
genetically modified organisms which
promise increased nutrition in fact
promise enormous environmental benefits
namely crops that need fewer pesticides
fewer fertilizers less acreage but like
water less water less resources less
resources so paradoxically that would be
a perfect case in which adherence to a
romantic ideology that what is natural
is good was human-made is bad actually
can harm the environment another aspect
of eco modernism is the recognition that
affluence in general is good for the
environment that when people are so poor
that electricity itself offers a big
leap in their living standards they'll
live without an awful lot of pollution
in return for electric current coming
out of the wall once you get a little
bit richer than and you started to choke
on smog and you can't see the horizon
you living in purple haze they you're
when you get a little bit richer you're
willing to pay for the pollution control
devices that give you the electricity
without all the pollution this seems to
be part of what's happening in China
where 50 years ago they were worried
more about you know after Mao's Great
Leap and the Cultural Revolution you
know they're they just want enough to
eat and they're willing to industrialize
without thinking about air pollution say
and now you're starting to see within
China more as they get richer as Chinese
people get richer they want cleaner air
absolutely it's a perfect example of
that and the fact that the world's most
polluted areas are poor countries
poverty is what is the greatest polluter
although this is where I think kind of
neo-marxist would say well that's
because we're you know the the rich part
of the world or the north or whatever
you want to call it the OECD countries
are pushing their immiseration there
were exporting our pollution that's not
literally true in that most of our
pollution
be exported because it's involved in a
generation of power and home heating and
so on also the fact that a lot of
pollution in the developing world comes
from burning wood especially indoors or
burning wood or dung and from
contaminated drinking water you write
the enlightened response to climate
change is to figure out how to get the
most energy with the least emission of
greenhouse gases and let's talk a bit
about climate change and first and
foremost you know you you believe that
climate change is happening and that
it's you know that human activity adds
to it right I mean I think how did you
come to appreciate nuclear energy and
how has that been how have people
responded to that appreciate well partly
from thinking it through that that we
really do need scalable abundant
affordable energy particularly in the
developing world where there's a moral
imperative to allow India and China and
Africa to enjoy the benefits that we've
enjoyed from abundant energy and the
fact that a lot of our dread of nuclear
energy comes because nuclear energy hits
all of our cognitive buttons for our
fear response it's novel we can imagine
a catastrophe it's a man-made as opposed
to natural there are a few salient
events that Lodge in our cultural memory
namely Three Mile Island Chernobyl and
now Fukushima despite the fact that the
the human damages in in each case was
trivial compared to what we tolerate
day-in day-out from burning coal yeah
could use focus on that a little bit I
mean it was I I hadn't thought about in
these terms but you mentioned what about
sixty or a hundred people died directly
in Chernobyl yeah and probably was a
slightly elevated cancer rate yeah
barely detectable among the yeah
children and whatnot later I know the
the UN did a follow-up study and it
turned out that children were fine who
were exposed but there was definitely a
higher case a little bit maybe just
barely above the noise and Fukushima
which is most recent but Three Mile
Island and this is something that kind
of haunted my childhood the press of the
China Syndrome
really you know so we're actually I'm
looking at a relatively minor event you
had a nuclear power plant but then a
movie that had been out for a couple of
weeks and then was it became a huge
thing and and by sheer coincidence had
the line that could contaminate an area
the size of Pennsylvania yeah and then
there's the no nukes concert the Doobie
Brothers and I think that irradiated the
Doobie Brothers more than that well yeah
I think so but is this a case where that
you know we can imagine the disaster
like the disastrous outcome in that
overwhelms any kind of cognitive ability
to be to talk about this stuff more
rationally that's right because the far
greater number of deaths that come from
fossil fuels from mining from
transporting from the pollution
particularly the particulate matter
there it just never happens all at once
in a photogenic event that makes the
news but coal probably kills according
to one estimate about a million people a
year from from pulmonary disease and and
coal mining and transport and but that
doesn't make the headlines so the
combination of just that that background
with the fact that that some of the
world's leading climate scientists like
my MIT colleague Kerry Emanuel like
James Henson themselves embraced nuclear
power because it simultaneously promises
a reduction in carbon emissions but with
provision of abundant energy that we
need and that the developing world means
see and and you talk about how this is
another thing we're kind of stuck in the
past because basically Three Mile Island
and then certainly later Chernobyl put
the ice on any American nuclear power
plants it's extremely difficult to get
licenses etc but there's been a lot of
progress in coming up with different
models and smaller power plants right
well there is the promise of fourth
generation nuclear technology that's not
the same as fusion but in the small
modular reactors that can be cranked out
in shipyards and anchored offshore and
moved out of the way of storms and
tsunamis and so on traveling wave
reactors thorium reactors liquid salt
reactors a number of technologies that
are kind of in the pipeline probably
won't come online for another decade or
more and within the pro-nuclear
environmental movement there's a bit of
a debate over whether we should just go
with tried-and-true second-generation
designs where it's climbed the
engineering learning curve and go and we
know what can go wrong and how to
prevent it versus putting the bat on
technologies of the future you also note
that France and Germany for example
which are countries and France in
particular which gets a lot of
electricity generation out of nuclear
power they're moving in the direction of
getting rid of them right and their
carbon emissions go up that's what
happened in Germany because when nuclear
power plants are taken offline they're
replaced by fossil fuels part of the
green Romantic movement in general or
romantic green movement is this idea
that you can get something for nothing
because you talk about if you wanted to
use wind energy or solar panels there's
a vast amount of area that would need to
be covered with these things in order to
generate the the demand for the type of
energy well and also the wind is
sometimes become dand the Sun doesn't
shine at night and clouds coming the Sun
doesn't shine most nights right most
assistant Li significant generalization
and so even with the enormous
penetration of photovoltaics which is
clearly a good thing there's a limit as
to how much of the energy demand it can
assume since a modern economy also has
to provide energy at night and there
long periods of time in which there's
pretty thick cloud cover and if we just
need a fossil fuel backup for for a
solar then it doesn't really help with
reducing carbon emissions because we
still have to have those gas or coal
plants in your reading of the data what
are the odds that a you know the worst
case scenario or a bad scenario is gonna
happen and then what is your what's your
favorite solution yeah I couldn't assign
a number to it it strikes me as high
enough that we should rationally prevent
it from happening we should reduce the
tail risk whether there would be a soft
landing of the so called luke warmer
position that acknowledges human-made
climate change but citizen votes it may
not be so bad after all or that we can
build our way out of it kind of by being
more my education yeah yeah windows done
a good job we're gonna have to do that
no matter what right because some of the
some degree of sea level rises is baked
in so that's gonna happen no matter what
and so obviously we shouldn't impoverish
society so we can't afford to do that
but but there's a range of putting
gruesome scenarios as to how high sea
levels could rise of possible flips like
the Gulf Stream being diverted that
would turn Europe into Siberia not
definitely gonna happen high enough of a
probability that it's incineration and
then you your preferred fix to this is
is a carbon tax how would that work and
what is its function the idea would be
to internalize the externality of
emitting carbon that could result in
climate change that harms everyone but
without that command and control
mechanism where someone decides what
source of energy we should use what
conservation methods we should adopt the
advantage of carbon pricing is that the
decisions are distributed across
hundreds of millions literally billions
of agents who can weigh off the various
trade-offs above the benefit that you
get from fossil fuels as opposed to the
cost that the carbon tax would would
impose and in some plans it ramps up
over time so there's an adjustment
period and all of that exactly so that
in fact that it can be that also
incentivizes the development of
lower zero-carbon energy sources where
if you know that you're gonna be paying
for a lot for carbon 10 years down the
line when you invest in technologies now
that would maybe allow you to avoid the
carbon tax altogether and then people
could make trade-offs for themselves as
to whether they want to eat less meat or
drive less depending on their own
priorities and it could be revenue
neutral depending on how its implemented
as Al Gore who I don't quote all that
often but tax what you burn not what you
earn right in arguing for that for a
trade-off and there are different ways
of implementing it I know people in the
libertarian movement are worried about a
carbon tax because it can become a brave
new source of revenue for governments to
do what you know for whatever they want
and things like that and how do you you
know I mean if that itself is the
concern then it could be offset by tax
reductions elsewhere right yeah yeah
well that's where pricing it so that you
don't create a weird market or a false
market that causes Mis investment or
malinvestment and and that risk can
never be zero P right no one's on this
yet yeah so but but I I think having one
is better than not having it
what about anti science or anti
enlighten meant people on the right
because it's you know there are some
kind of people on the right who hate
modernity because of environmental
concerns but it seems that the
anti-enlightenment attitudes on the
right come from different sources who
are the major players there and you know
what what's motivating them in your
sense some of them are religious that we
can't play God by extending human
lifespans or conversely that we don't
even have to worry about climate change
because God wouldn't let any bad thing
happen were it's part of his plan worth
by that I mean that's a pretty safe
position yeah I mean that that that's
happened with no I right right yeah part
of it comes from my someone's called
Theo conservatism the idea that the
Enlightenment roots of
the American social order we're kind of
a big mistake that it just has led to
relativism and to homosexuality and
pornography women whether you have
welcomed worse yes just just decadence
and degeneration and that but because
the right to life liberty and pursuit of
happiness is just too tepid for a
morally robust society so we need
something some sort of rock-solid
principles which convenient we are
provided by religion particularly
Catholicism because Protestantism itself
has become too liberal according to this
this mindset and this was a movement
that distrusts science for the
Promethean usurping of power from from
the gods
especially when it mergers with with
classical liberalism and i other
Enlightenment values so it seems to me
that in in a way to there are two major
legacies of the Enlightenment one is
scientific progress so the idea that we
can we can and should investigate all
aspects of the natural world and of the
social world and get to understand that
better and that that in a weird way
leads to things like Darwinism where or
other forms of scientific determinism
where we we know why things happen and
they're going to happen in pretty
predictable ways that limit our autonomy
an individual a sense of individualism
on the other hand there is the political
legacy of the Enlightenment which is the
idea that each of us should be able to
run our lives more than then we might
have in the past because we're all
rational agents and thinking agents and
should be given that life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness and is there a
tension between those two legacies
because in order to you know life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
means we have an open society and open
society means we sometimes come across
scientific discoveries that tell us well
we're not that special or you know
you're never gonna be a baseball player
yeah you know I'm never gonna be a
Harvard professor
and that seems you know how do we
maintain equality in the political
sphere wall everything in our knowledge
starts to tell us where more and more
unequal we have to embrace the the ideal
of political equality and equality of
opportunity and quality of treatment
under the law as opposed to equality of
outcome so that's innocent I think
inescapable consequence of the fact that
we're not close we're genetically
different men and women aren't
indistinguishable not all individuals
with any sex are indistinguishable but
it really has nothing to do with equal
treatment before the law if you adopt a
principle that we're not going to
prejudge an individual by the
characteristics of his or her group and
I mean that's a moral political decision
I think it's justifiable and it's one
that we can stick to do you worry at all
though that when people start talking
about intelligence even and it doesn't
even have to go to you know kind of
racial or ethnic group disparities among
averages and groups which may or may not
exist or exist it may not mean it mean
as much as people want but among
individuals like you know if we start to
find out more and more of like well this
person really is incapable of doing this
level of thought work how do we maintain
commitments political equality I don't
think there's any attention to that and
political equality you get that person
or chance I try to maximize what he or
she can accomplish within the envelope
of possibilities made available by by
nature we know that there's considerable
scope for for human improvement just
because education matters and
institutions that result in economic
growth have worked democracy has
increased violence is decreased so the
when when you put together
billions of people particularly since
we're we are even though we're products
of evolution
one of things evolution gave us is this
brain that is massively complex not
completely predictable as a lot of
randomness that goes on in both of
formation of the brain and at its
day-to-day operation the brain processes
information and information can be
exchanged without loss if I
if I teach you something it's not that I
subtracted from my store of knowledge
but it can therefore proliferate and
multiply it can accumulate and the fact
that we can we're cognitive creatures
that live by ideas that that we can
share we can innovate accumulate means
there's huge scope for social progress
even though who are fitted with bubbly
the same brain as our ancestors
thousands of years ago so we're still
waiting for that firmware update it's
always you know it's like an Apple
iPhone it's always going Thanks let's
talk about the kind of postmodern
critique of our post structural
postmodern critique of enlightenment and
you you talk about people like Nietzsche
Foucault Michel Foucault jean-paul
Sartre Max Horkheimer and Theodor Adorno
what was the nature of their critique
and is it substantially different from
some of the things that we've already
talked about didn't take long after the
Enlightenment for there to be a counter
Enlightenment movement the the 19th
century romantics
the cultural pessimists like
Schopenhauer and Nietzsche which led to
the Frankfurt School of Horkheimer and
Adorno and to existentialists and then
to post modernists which rejected pretty
much every one of the Enlightenment
ideals reason was just a pretext to
exert power the individual was a myth
that the individuals are just embedded
in a culture and it's the culture that's
real one strain of that led to a lot of
the soil nationalism that what really
exists is the culture and we're just
sort of cells of a super organism
there's no such thing as objective truth
but just competing narratives and far
from their being progress there has been
deterioration in any moment now the
entire society will collapse did you go
through an existentialist phase at any
point or a romantic phase no I really
didn't for one thing that the prose was
so impenetrable I just didn't enjoy
reading it you know
movin Sarkar that's dirty you know there
being nothing that was a tough yeah
that's true
yeah and Heidegger is worst of the bunch
really you know Kenya was a great was a
fine novice but actually I actually
hated the the stranger yeah I thought
was a psychopathic I think that's the
point but I don't pretend to understand
it Heidegger in many ways I guess is the
ultimate of this anti enlightenment and
no way yeah well I was gonna say because
Heidegger was an actual Nazis which was
a very romantic counter Enlightenment
movement and he at one point I know even
Herbert Marcuse a disowned him after
after World War Two he wrote an essay
where he compared concentration camps to
kind of factory farming you know it is
kind of like even more Cuza was like
yeah yeah that's a little bit much you
know something wrong with your your
brain pattern but are there critiques
then of enlightenment that you find
convincing because you kind of push away
all of the the negative things so say
something like Nazism in a way is a kind
of perverted understanding of or
totalitarianism in general is often
considered and this I guess is Adorno
and Horkheimer saying well you know
enlightenment is totalitarian because
it's gonna fill every aspect of human
being and that we see this in Nazism or
in Stalinism or in maoism where and you
know you say well no they weren't these
are perversions of enlightenment but but
no I yeah not since it was not an
Enlightenment movement it was I don't
think getting trace it back to Adam
Smith and David Hume and Spinoza and
James Madison I mean it really was
counter enlightenment and valorizing the
tribal for the individual in its
iconography venerated pagan origins and
rootedness in nature and
tribal symbolism it was opposed to
liberal movements of the 19th century
that tried to generate wealth reduce in
justices maximize flourishing of as many
people as possible these were all in a
themá-- to to be and I might add the
Catholic Church in the 19th century I
mean the first Vatican Council was
explicitly aimed against democracy or a
representative government and capitalism
or less a fair because it precisely as
enlightenment
you know outcomes of the Enlightenment
but here's a quote from the mande
Marquis de Condorcet ability of man
which I first encountered in high expect
the the counter-revolution of science
subtitled studies on the abuses of
Reason any this is from the Marquis who
was very much a man of the Enlightenment
and who died in the French Revolution
the sole foundation for belief in the
Natural Sciences is this idea that the
general laws directing the phenomena of
the universe known or unknown are
necessary and constant why should this
principle be any less true for the
development of the intellectual and
moral faculties of man than for other
operations of nature our hopes for the
future condition of the human race can
be subsumed under three important heads
the abolition of inequality between
nations the progress of equality within
each nation and the true perfection of
mankind and I mean the marquis de
condorcet is a paradigmatic it's waiting
away and it seems like this kind of
hubris really of the idea of moving from
natural phenomenon to human phenomenon
yeah it makes total sense and it's a
leap and you know isn't that part of the
Enlightenment legacy that we always need
to be kind of working against yeah and
the Enlightenment itself had many
contradictory strains and they argued
against each other so it's it's in the
very nature of the Enlightenment that it
wasn't a doctrine catechism of beliefs
and so so be impossible to say
everything about the Enlightenment was
is worthy because they disagreed with
each other
and there also was an enlightened critic
of the Enlightenment from Edmund Burke
that we're just not smart enough to
design a society from rational
principles that we should respect
tradition and social structures even if
we can't explain their rationale because
they keep us from there from from
teetering over the brain and obviously
his great example of that was the French
Revolution which we started the calendar
and everything and leveled all sorts of
past institutions so the way here's the
way I would put it though but yeah so
the Enlightenment as a you know as a
party as a doctrine NASA as a movement
obviously has simple flaws because these
were you know they're just guys they
couldn't gotten everything right on the
first try they disagreed with each other
there's a lot of stuff they didn't know
they didn't know evolution they didn't
know thermodynamics so it's really the
ideals that I associate with the
Enlightenment namely reason science and
humanism that that we ought to defend
and the thing about reason is it can
always step back and take into account
flaws in reason as it's been practiced
up to that point in fact that's the only
way that we could in theory uncover
problems with the way people the reason
is we're using reason as the the
benchmark against which we say that
people have fallen short and it can give
us the next steps to making us all the
more rational and there's just no way
out of Reason if you're talking in the
first place you talk in the book about
how politics makes us dumb and you talk
about this both in terms of our
politicization makes us dumb both in
politics but then also in academia let's
talk about those how first of it what's
the general argument that politicization
of things makes us dumb what's going on
there people identify with really what
you might call tribes and then leftism
and rainism
become tribes and we'll evaluate any
idea empirical or policy proposal in
terms of how well it conforms with a
particular set of ideas that happen to
be associated with that try
will resist evidence to the contrary
will demonize those they disagree with
and there are in fact studies that show
that people even evaluating data from a
hypothetical experiment if it's
politically neutral like the efficacy of
a skin cream they'll do a decent job in
interpreting the numbers but as soon as
it's a political hot button
like like concealed weapon laws then
they'll systematically mislead the data
in the direction that favors the
position of Saudis associate with their
coalition yeah there's a like a cottage
industry of where you know you you go
out with a bunch of Trump positions and
read them to liberals and also like oh I
think that's a pretty good idea until
they hear it's from Trump or vice versa
or Trump is people will hate them but
it's like this is your guy precisely
well what are the ways around that
ideally it would be reminding people
that that this phenomenon exists that
that political tribalism makes them make
math errors that it is a human failing
that we should evaluate policies based
in terms of evidence as to what their
what their effects are and how well they
can form with what we want how do you
know when you take like the argument
from Authority away or traditionally
that's like you know I feel so it's in
yeah that really hurts if you if you
agree with it right that is the
idealization but of course if we were
rational enough to accept that we
probably wouldn't have fallen into the
trap list for the first place well you
were part of it you know with perhaps
with a more of an appeal to our
emotional themselves would be to find
spokespeople on who are branded with the
opposite coalition to speak in favor of
a particular position I say in the case
of climate change you'd be far more
effective if there were people on the
libertarian right who were chosen as
spokesmen as opposed to say Al Gore who
is the Democratic candidate for
president and a vice president and to
frame issues in a way that doesn't
immediately trigger
your tribal affiliations and and we do
know that issues can flip an example
that I mentioned is environmentalism
used to be thought of as a right-wing
position because these were gentlemen in
their country estates who valued the
view and duck hunters who wanted the
habitat preserved for their ducks
whereas serious progressives cared about
real issues no they want to put a dam
everywhere so that they could provide
energy for Hillbillies and poor people
so well you know in the book and I I
took this you know
seriously you chastised the libertarian
right for embracing a rigid Dogma over
serious introspection on things and you
you talk about how kind of like a worry
about too much regulation immediately
becomes it's not even a slippery slope
libertarians will go from okay this this
regulation gets introduced and then
we're at you were at the final terminus
of the Road to Serfdom
Thanks next thing you know were
Venezuela yeah and so what are ways and
one one example I use or one
illustration is the idea of a few years
ago raising the top marginal tax rate
and I guess this was under Clinton from
36 percent to 39.6 percent which was
widely seen on the free market right
certainly it's like okay this is gonna
kill the economy yes or it's it's the
first step for jackbooted Stormtroopers
right taking away our liberty right is
the slippery slope argument is that
something that came into practice in the
Enlightenment I'm wondering I don't
remember a lot of slopes in the Bible so
but then in terms of academia and the
way politicization or politics makes
people dumb in academia you you quote at
one point john maynard keynes is a
phrase that all madmen and authority are
usually in the grip of the ideas of some
debt economists or political philosopher
how does this politicization effect you
know particularly you I mean you're
you're an academic you're an
intellectual in the Academy what are
what are the worst elements or outgrowth
of the
kind of politicization as it affects you
on a daily basis well there's some
hypotheses that are that are hard to
advance without being branded as a
business or a baddest the in fact that
men and women aren't indistinguishable
the fact that intelligence is in good
part heritable the fact that parenting
doesn't have a lasting effect on the
personalities of children the fact that
rates of crime differ across ethnic
groups the fact that policing has a
large effect on the crime rate i'm
incarceration as well that I mean I
could I could go on or the one that we
just mentioned the fact that free market
economies are both lead to greater
prosperity and greater peace is one of
the biggest problems that because of the
politics of these situations you're not
even supposed to discuss them or
investigate them or kind of walk around
them like they're a car on a used car
lot and kick the tires and everything
yeah is that the real problem with the
current academic well I think they're
too close one of them is simply that we
can't converge on the most likely
hypothesis if there's some hypotheses
that are just undiscussables as a John
Stuart Mill said he who knows only his
own case knows those little of that and
so it's only in the crucible of ideas
and debate that you can converge on on
the truth or the most likely hypothesis
the other is that you by making certain
hypotheses undiscussables shor people
who stumble across them outside of the
the sandbox of academia and they will
not have an opportunity to debate them
either and they can often attach
themselves to the most extreme versions
since they don't get any pushback and in
fact can feel empowered that they've
discovered a truth that's undiscussables
in academia all the more reason to think
that they bet that they have the truth
and so you get communities in the
alt-right that often embrace quite
liberal extreme views because they feel
so exhilarated that they've come across
them and then they don't get any
pushback I mean in exam I mean if the
silly example would be Milo your novel
is saying that because women place a
greater emphasis on family versus career
in their their lifestyle trade-offs we
should keep women out of medical school
because they're just going to drop out
and have babies so that's the kind of
extreme alternative to the dogma that
men and women are indistinguishable I
mean it is actually a fact that there is
a difference in the distribution of life
priorities between men and women of
course it doesn't mean that all men
place 100% of weight on their career and
0% on family nor vice-versa for for
women there's an enormous overlap and of
course there are moral and political
arguments why even if it were the case
that that more women drop out we would
not want to keep them out of medical
school
but that debate doesn't even take place
if you can't even acknowledge the fact
that men and women have defendants in
the university it's not the Mylo
DiNapoli's of the world that are keeping
that conversation from happening that's
right yes but they then making these
views can confess right in these
alternatives online communities likewise
another example that I'm given is that
you can't really understand crime in
this country without noting that there
are pretty severe differences in rate of
incidents across different ethnic groups
and races if so that's almost
undiscussables go to the FBI website and
look
homicide statistics for
african-americans and european-americans
in there pretty different but if that's
undiscussables and then you stumble
across it could you go to fbi.gov then
you might think oh well it just shows
that african-americans are inherently
more violent which of course is nonsense
because rates of crime across ethnic
groups are never identical and at other
points in American history it was the
Irish Americans who had the high rates
of violent crime we were number one for
a while I mean so so you could you could
actually by suppressing a basic
statistical fact it can actually
encourage racism in these alternative
communities because they never get
pushed back in an arena in which all
hypotheses are out there and their
limitations can be rationally discussed
what happened because I mean you've been
haunting universities for you know the
better part of 40 years right as a
student and as a professor I can
remember in grad school in the late 80s
and early 90s I had a lot of professors
who had gone to Berkeley in the 60s and
they're a whole ideal I mean they didn't
I was libertarian back then and they
didn't particularly agree with me about
a lot of things but they were interested
in discussing and arguing them that
seems to have faded from the University
what has gone into that where the
university is no longer the place where
you argue all ideas you know and get rid
of the ones that really can't you know
go more than a few rounds without being
revealed as you know lightweight yes I
don't know the exact us Jim and there
was a fair amount of intolerance in the
in the 70s sure it was not exactly a
golden age for speech a lot of speakers
were as we now say deep platformed ieo
wilson when he published so so we all
are getting reported water poured over
the head that was like winning that was
a good day for chanting mobs yeah and so
on it does seem to have gotten worse in
the last 5 to 10 years and I don't know
if it's that the the baby boom
generation that itself had some
intolerance toward a non leftist views
then became the establishment and so
they established norms that then the
millennial generation in the internal
there's the theory that because
Millennials have been so over parented
they are you know there's snowflakes
they can't stand hurtful ideas meaning
ones that they have never heard before
that's one theory I'm a little skeptical
you say coming more from the faculty or
or people on on camp you know adults on
campus or the students so I think a lot
of it actually comes from neither comes
from the student life bureaucracy the
various Dean's and associate Dean's
and title nine administrators and firm
interaction administrators that have
formed this new guilt that operates out
of the control of the the ordinary
university chain of command with the
President and a Provost who knows from
the faculty and presumably have some
commitment to intellectual values this
is an autonomous culture that moves
laterally from university to university
they have their own norms and they the
control a lot of student life has kind
of been outsourced to this bureaucracy
it's absolutely burdened and so I think
I'm guessing that some of the phenomenon
is that they've been the intolerant
students have been embedded by the face
of the university that they deal with
most directly one of the great values of
the book to me was you you discuss CP
snows early 60s two cultures essay where
he talked about scientific culture and a
more kind of humanities based culture
and that what he saw then as a terrible
gulf that was growing up between those
and and you argue and I think pretty
persuasively that that gulf has not been
shrunk at all it's if anything it's
bigger how does that play into this I
mean is there are the humanities which
everywhere seamen retreat in university
in terms of majors in terms of funding
in terms of kind of prestige are they
part of the problem here in dismissing
of enlightenment values in academia yeah
I think so not so much the humanities in
the sense of every scholar who looks at
works of art and texts and histories of
history of ideas but there is a kind of
culture in the ethnographer sense in
large parts of academia and cultural
criticism that replicates this gulf
that's no document in the early 60s and
and snow was viciously attacked by a
literary critic named fr leavis and it's
quite remarkable to see a similar debate
playing out today a hostility in this
culture to science being part of the
human accomplishment as opposed to just
giving us some useful gadgets even a
hostility to what I consider the
Enlightenment the value of enhancing
human flourishing everywhere leave us
attacked Snowe who I think quite
presently said that science is not just
intellectually beautiful in explaining
how the cosmos works in deep and elegant
theories but it has an enormous moral
promise in alleviating early death and
malnutrition and disease in the
developing world kind of anticipating
the whole UN sustainable development
goals and Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation and the fantastic progress
that was made long after snow died and
lead us said well who cares about babies
in there in there in the third world
what really matters in life is
appreciation of excellent literature
that's what we should live for this is a
weird dichotomy but I still see it now
in and it shed light on a mindset that
otherwise I could not understand but
I've seen three or four the proponents
of the humanities saying that what what
really matters is a previous consuming
elite art that's the highest moral value
and if somehow vulgar to worry about
calories in the in the developing world
I mean who cares about that that's
boring talk about I mean you make a case
for the humanities what is that briefly
and and
is that a way of kind of you know at
least finding people in the humanities
that are that are interested in having a
dialogue rather than kind of just
excoriating yeah and a lot of people in
humanities out well the amenities are
defined as what the study of state
products of the human mind of this
symbolic creations of including art
ideas political philosophies and so on
then that of course is they shouldn't be
a debate between science and Humanities
we've obviously got to nurture
scholarship of artists and writers and
thinkers past and present and that has
to be reinterpreted every generation
with new understanding both of sources
and of the greater intellectual context
but it's just this particular set of
assumptions that has happens to have
taken over big sectors of the humanities
that I think is a source of the problem
including obscurantism in expression the
fact that the by far the most turgid
jargon written prose comes out of post
modernist humanities the deep cultural
pessimism and hatred of the institutions
of modernity the the equation of liberal
democracy with fascism they deep the the
feeling that society is in ever
worsening spiral of decline and the the
lack of appreciation I think of the
institutions of liberal democracy that
have made humanities possible then it
made them flourish that cluster of ideas
which is not the same as in humanities
but just happens to have descended over
large sectors of the academic humanities
you're making a defence of the
Enlightenment you know which means that
you're worried about its salience E and
Earth's you know its relevance to
contemporary intellectual life and
cultural life are you optimistic that it
will you know that your intervention
here will help kind of restart a debate
or kind of at least delineate the terms
better the honest answer is I don't know
I think would be grandiose to say that
my book will will allow to change the
situation and do
doing what I can but the optimism that I
that I'm associated with in this book
isn't just thinking that everything is
bound to get better it just has to
there's some law of nature that will
carry everything I have ever upward it's
really more a defense of an empirical
defense of progress we have made
accomplishments they're precious
we're always in danger of losing them
and what will happen going forward
depends very much on the choices that we
make now well leave it there we've been
talking with Steven Pinker he's the
author most recently of enlightenment
now the case for reason science humanism
and progress save thanks retire thank so
much Nicky for reason I'm Nikolas
[Music]